Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, as you might well be aware, the road to becoming a qualified psychologist does not always run smoothly. And of course, with the vast number of people who are wanting to join the profession and become qualified and the small amount of jobs available, it must mean that it doesn't work out for everybody. And whilst that might be a painful consideration or a realisation to make, I thought it was a useful angle that we needed to cover within the podcast. So that is exactly what today's episode is going to be about. It's a guest interview episode with someone who started out on the route to professional psychology qualification, but then later had a different course and has had a different outcome. Now, this episode covers different bits and pieces that you might not use in your clinical practice,
我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。如你所知，成为一名合格心理学家的道路并不总是一帆风顺的。当然，由于想要进入这个行业并获得资格的人数众多，而可提供的职位却很少，这意味着并不是每个人都能如愿以偿。虽然这可能是一个令人痛苦的考量或现实，但我认为这是一个我们在播客中需要探讨的有用角度。所以，这正是今天节目的主题。这是一期嘉宾访谈，嘉宾曾走在通往专业心理学资格的道路上，但后来选择了不同的方向，并有了不同的结果。这期节目涵盖了你可能在临床实践中不会用到，
or that you might not have heard of as well. So listen with an open mind, and I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi, I would like to welcome Fiona Maguire to the podcast. Fiona is a coach, a speaker and an author. Hi Fiona. Hi Maureen, how are you? I'm really well, thank you, really well. Enjoying a little of sunshine today, which is nice after all of the rain. How are you? Yeah, the same thing. The sun has come out and it just lifts things up, doesn't it, really? It's fantastic. Yeah. So I know I'm like becoming an old hand here talking about LinkedIn, but we did meet on LinkedIn, didn't we? We did.
或者你可能从未听说过的内容。所以请保持开放的心态来聆听，我期待在节目后与你交流。你好，我想欢迎Fiona Maguire来到播客。Fiona是一位教练、演讲者和作家。你好，Fiona。你好，Marianne，你好吗？我很好，谢谢，非常好。今天享受了一点阳光，在经历了这么多雨天之后，这感觉真好。你呢？是的，我也是。太阳出来了，心情也随之明朗了，不是吗？太棒了。是的。我知道我在这里谈论LinkedIn已经快成老手了，但我们确实是在LinkedIn上认识的，对吧？是的。
I love it. Do you love LinkedIn? Yeah yeah I'm getting to it. I ignored it for years but but now yeah I'm really getting into it. I love engaging with new people and finding out what they're doing and you know how we can work together collaborate or help each other in any way. It's fantastic. Yeah, and actually, I think it's a really good place to be if you are an aspiring psychologist, I think anyway, because you can connect with loads of people that are doing the job that you want to do. But you're not an aspiring psychologist anymore.
我喜欢它。你喜欢LinkedIn吗？是的，我正在适应它。我多年来一直忽略它，但现在我真的很投入。我喜欢与新朋友互动，了解他们在做什么，以及我们如何合作或以任何方式互相帮助。这太棒了。是的，实际上，如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，我认为这是一个非常好的地方，因为你可以与许多从事你想要从事的工作的人建立联系。但你已经不再是一位有抱负的心理学家了。
You are a coach, a speaker and an author. Could you tell us a little bit about what you do currently, Fiona? Yeah, so I'm an intuitive transformational coach so I use all my psychological training but I work on all levels of people so my main superpower if you like is my intuition and I've really honed my intuition so I can access people's unconscious mind I can access what's going on inside of them and I ask them questions because if they own it then you know that's when we can really do the work wherever I say oh this is what I see they don't particularly own it and it doesn't
你现在是一位教练、演讲者和作家。Fiona，你能告诉我们你目前的工作吗？好的，我是一位直觉转型教练，所以我运用我所有的心理学训练，但我是在人们的各个层面进行工作。如果可以的话，我的主要超能力是我的直觉，我已经磨练了我的直觉，所以我可以进入人们的潜意识，我可以接触到他们内心正在发生的事情，并向他们提问。因为如果他们自己意识到这一点，那么我们才能真正开展工作。如果我说“这是我看到的”，他们并不一定认同，这也不会
have as much awe-inspiring you know it's not a deep insight that they get inside of themselves. So I work with their intuition. I work with their unconscious mind, their energy, their conscious mind, their emotions, their thinking, all of them. And my aim is to obviously solve the problem they come to me for, but also for them to get a deeper understanding of who they really are. Great. Thank you. for but also for them to get a deeper understanding of who they really are great thank you and obviously a lot of our listeners might have spiritual or kind of holistic views and beliefs themselves but when we try to put that into practice sort of in an nhs setting that's difficult
产生那种令人敬畏的深刻洞察。所以我与他们的直觉合作。我与他们的潜意识、能量、意识、情绪、思维，所有这些层面合作。我的目标显然是解决他们来找我时想要解决的问题，同时也让他们对自己到底是谁有更深刻的理解。太棒了，谢谢。当然，我们的许多听众可能自己也有精神层面或整体论的观点和信仰，但当我们试图在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）的环境中将其付诸实践时，这很困难，
because because of the evidence base is there an evidence base for for the way that you work yeah so I'm not I'm not people don't have to do anything spiritual with me they don't have to go there if if they don't want to but what what I actually do now is I talk about something that's called the three principles and it was also coined the inside out perspective perspective, which Michael Neal called it that. And there's a lot of evidence for that. And that's basically the psychological theory of perception, how perception really works and therefore how the mind really works. And then when you realise that you don't live in reality,
因为证据基础的问题。你所采用的工作方式有证据支持吗？是的，人们不必和我一起做任何精神层面的事情，如果他们不想，他们不必去触碰那个领域。但我现在实际上谈论的是一种叫做“三大原则”（Three Principles）的东西，它也被称为“由内而外”的视角，这是Michael Neill提出的。这方面有很多证据。这基本上是关于感知的心理学理论，即感知是如何真正运作的，从而了解思维是如何真正运作的。当你意识到你并不生活在现实中，
you live in your own thought-created reality, which is your own perception of everything and psychology agrees with that you know wouldn't you agree that psychology agrees with that it's like a social construction isn't it and metacognitions and thoughts about thoughts about thoughts and all of that jazz so I absolutely agree with that angle yeah so as soon as people really this has been my experience my own personal experience and the experience of working with clients, as soon as people realize that they're not there thinking and they don't have to be identified with their thinking,
你生活在你自己思想创造的现实中，也就是你对一切事物的感知，心理学也认同这一点。难道你不认为心理学认同这一点吗？这就像是一种社会建构，对吧？还有元认知，关于思想的思想，以及所有这些东西。所以我绝对同意这个角度。是的，所以一旦人们真正意识到——这是我的经验，我个人的经验，以及与客户工作的经验——一旦人们意识到他们不是他们的思想，他们不必与他们的思想认同，
they then paradoxically start wondering and thinking, well, who am I and what am I? And if I'm not experiencing the reality then how how do I experience the reality and when they really open up to that question if I'm not experiencing the reality does that explain why um you know I sometimes have an argument with my spouse and it's like we're living in completely different worlds I don't understand why he she is upset about something and you know they're they're thinking the same thing and it's almost like we're talking from different universes it's like that saying isn't it there's three versions
他们就会矛盾地开始思考：“那么我是谁？我是什么？如果我不是在体验现实，那么我该如何体验现实？”当他们真正对这个问题敞开心扉时——如果我不是在体验现实，这是否解释了为什么……你知道，我有时会和配偶争吵，感觉我们生活在完全不同的世界里？我不明白为什么他/她会对某事感到不安，而他们也在想同样的事情，这几乎就像我们来自不同的宇宙。就像那句谚语说的，有三个版本
of of an eventuality there's your version their version and the truth and it's yeah it's what perception what angle you're looking at that from and also you know what comes before and what what trauma might have been around for one or both parties as to what might be a truly mindful reaction to what's going on now and what might have happened or be a ripple from things that have happened years ago. Yeah, absolutely. And also, you know, for me, when I first really got that, you know, actually I'm just creating lots of stories in my head. That's the language I put on it. These are just stories.
的事件：你的版本、他们的版本和真相。这取决于感知，取决于你从什么角度看待它。还有，你知道，之前发生了什么，以及一方或双方可能存在什么样的创伤，这可能会影响到对当前发生的事情的反应，以及可能发生的事情，或者仅仅是多年前发生的事情的涟漪。是的，绝对是。而且，对我来说，当我第一次真正理解这一点时，我意识到我只是在脑子里编造了很多故事。这就是我给它贴的标签。这些只是故事。
And, yes, some of them to my brain seem valid because this happened in my past of course I'm going to act like this or of course I'm going to act like that well and then I was like hold on but am I really present am I here am I really present inside of myself knowing what's going on inside of me and am I really present with with the other person and if you're in your head too busy with your own story then you can't be present you can't really listen you can't really hear and a lot of people are just too busy thinking about what they're going to say next to actually hear what the person said to them. I hear you and that's a really important consideration for many of our audience as well who might be developing or striving for a career as a therapist
是的，其中一些对我的大脑来说似乎是合理的，因为这在我的过去发生过，我当然会这样表现，或者我当然会那样表现。然后我就想：“等等，我真的在当下吗？我在这里吗？我真的在内心深处知道我内心发生了什么吗？我真的与另一个人在一起吗？”如果你脑子里太忙于自己的故事，你就无法处于当下，你无法真正倾听，你无法真正听到。很多人太忙于思考接下来要说什么，以至于无法真正听到对方对他们说了什么。我听到了，这对我们的许多听众来说也是一个非常重要的考量，他们可能正在发展或努力成为一名治疗师。
have you got any tips for ways that we can improve that ability to stay present and not be focused on you know is it the listening to hear rather than the listening to speak? Yeah, one of the things that was said to me, and I've got one of my own, but one of the things that was said to me once, and it was part of a bigger course that I was on, and Michael Neal said it, he said, listen as if you're listening to music. And there was something in that that just dropped for me. So maybe that doesn't drop for other people. So my advice would be to center yourself, to ground, to become into yourself and to know what's going on for you,
你有什么建议可以帮助我们提高保持当下的能力，而不是专注于——你知道，是倾听为了理解，而不是倾听为了说话吗？是的，有人曾对我这样说，我自己也有一个体会，但有一次有人对我说了这样一句话，那是我参加的一个更大课程的一部分，Michael Neill说的，他说：“倾听就像你在听音乐一样。”那一刻，有些东西对我来说豁然开朗。也许这对其他人来说并不适用。所以我的建议是让自己居中，扎根，进入自己的内心，了解自己身上发生了什么，
but to be centered in that, to not lost in your thinking or your emotions or your feelings, but to be centered. And to ground is one of the things I give away for free on my website like how to ground great and I guess I was thinking about what about the bits of music that really resonate with you and you want to join in or you want to sing and you want to stand up and dance are those the bits where you get the natural interaction that's kind of spontaneous rather than pre-thought that's really interesting isn't that amazing you've seen it differently I love the way you've seen it but you've seen it differently for me it was like when I'm listening to music
但要保持中心，不要迷失在你的思想、情绪或感受中，而是要保持中心。扎根是我在网站上免费提供的内容之一，比如如何扎根。太棒了。我在想，那些真正引起你共鸣的音乐片段，你想加入其中，或者你想唱歌，你想站起来跳舞，那些是你获得自然互动、那种自发而非预先思考的互动的时刻吗？这真的很有趣，不是吗？太神奇了，你看到了不同的角度。我喜欢你看到它的方式，但你看到的和我不同。对我来说，就像当我听音乐时，
I'm there I'm an open vessel I'm just with it and I'm letting it flow through me. And then whatever may happen, you know, maybe a response to that. So I love what you said, maybe a response to that. Is that I want to dance or is that I want to join in or I just want to be with it or be closer to it. So if you think of the music as a person, and I really love what you just said, then that's it, that's true connection, isn't it? That you want to be more with them. You want to dance with them. You want to hear more of what they've got to say
我在那里，我是一个开放的容器，我只是与它同在，我让它流过我。然后无论发生什么，你知道，也许是对它的回应。所以我喜欢你说的，也许是对它的回应。是我想要跳舞，还是我想要加入，或者我只是想与它同在，或者更接近它。所以如果你把音乐想象成一个人，我真的很喜欢你刚才说的，那么这就是真正的连接，不是吗？你想与他们更多地在一起。你想与他们共舞。你想听到更多他们要说的话，
or you just want to be in the flow of their company. That's beautiful connections. Oh, lovely. Although my husband, who is a musician, would say, just listen to the music. Like, they've done a good job, you know. There are many ways to look at the same consideration and I understand that you um originally were on a path to um to psychology is that right
或者你只是想沉浸在他们的陪伴中。那是美丽的连接。哦，太可爱了。虽然我丈夫是一位音乐家，他会说：“就听音乐吧。就像，他们已经做得很好了一样。”看待同一个问题有很多种方式，我理解你……你最初是在通往心理学的道路上，对吧？
yeah after my degree I I done the first single honours degree um at the University of Luton it was called now it's now called the University of Bedfordshire and looks a lot different. I wanted to be a psychologist and my second job as an assistant psychologist, stroke group worker, was in what was called a psychiatric unit for adolescents, so that now called young people. And that was great. But my first thing that i noticed was
是的，在我获得学位后，我在卢顿大学（University of Luton）完成了第一个单荣誉学位，现在它被称为贝德福德郡大学（University of Bedfordshire），看起来大不相同。我想成为一名心理学家，我的第二份工作是助理心理学家兼小组工作者，是在一个所谓的青少年精神病科，现在被称为年轻人。那很棒。但我注意到的第一件事是，
okay so i know all these theories i know what schizophrenia is and i want bulimia is and anorexia is uh multiple personality disorder as they called it then you know i i know all of these things now bipolar but these kids like those three kids over there they're all schizophrenic but they're all completely different so how does the theory psychology go with that so I had questions right from the beginning and it was fascinating um but you know for me and I don't even remember how long it was. I need to look at my CV that I worked there full time. And then I had a car crash leaving the hospital one day.
好吧，我知道所有这些理论，我知道什么是精神分裂症，我知道什么是贪食症和厌食症，还有当时所谓的“多重人格障碍”。你知道，我现在知道所有这些事情，还有双相情感障碍。但这些孩子，就像那边的三个孩子，他们都被诊断为精神分裂症，但他们完全不同。那么心理学理论是如何解释这一点的呢？所以我从一开始就有疑问，这很迷人。但是，你知道，对我来说，我不记得那是多久以前的事了。我需要看看我的简历，看看我在那里全职工作了多久。然后有一天，我离开医院时发生了车祸。
Lucky enough, on the driveway of the hospital, I hit snow and went into a tree. And on the impact of, you know, hitting the tree, my inner wisdom just said, you have to leave. And I just intuitively knew that I had to leave that job because I was burning out. And I know why I was burning out. Could you guide us through that a little bit, what that felt like at the time and how that was showing up for you in your work and personal life, if that's okay? Yeah, so, like, of course we had protocols. We had ways we were meant to work and everything else. And it was definitely around, I think it was around Christmas time
幸运的是，在医院的车道上，我撞到了雪，冲进了一棵树。在撞击的那一刻，我的内在智慧告诉我：“你必须离开。”我直觉地知道我必须辞掉那份工作，因为我快要精疲力竭了。我知道我为什么会精疲力竭。你能引导我们了解一下当时的感觉，以及这在你的工作和个人生活中是如何表现出来的吗？如果可以的话。是的，当然，我们有规程。我们有被要求的工作方式等等。这绝对是在……我想是在圣诞节前后，
this realisation hit. It was definitely snowing you know and uh i just noticed that what we just talked about you know i i was a i was a buddhist and um at the time and i really believed in being present with the young people and that meant to me just really listening, really being with them. And that had the benefit of them just really calming down. Like these were psychoactively ill children. They were not in a hospital, in a unit for nothing. They had, you know, severe mental illnesses, you know, psychoactively mental illnesses.
这种顿悟出现了。当时确实在下雪，我注意到我们刚才谈到的事情。我当时是一名佛教徒，我真的相信要与年轻人保持在当下，对我来说，这意味着真正倾听，真正与他们在一起。这带来的好处是他们真的平静了下来。这些是患有精神疾病的孩子。他们不是无缘无故地住在医院的病房里。他们患有严重的精神疾病。
And people acknowledge that I worked differently, and in the whole they were happy with that because I was definitely getting results. And it was great that I was able to be with the kids at all different times of day. Sometimes when the psychologist wasn't there, so I seen them at all different times. But what I knew at the time is that I
人们承认我的工作方式不同，总的来说他们对此感到满意，因为我确实取得了成果。很高兴我能在一天中的不同时间与孩子们在一起。有时心理学家不在，所以我会在不同的时间见到他们。但我当时知道的是，我
felt what the children were feeling and I had real empathy with them but to a degree that it didn't seem like my peers had and um I I could I either had a really good idea of what they were feeling or I literally felt it physically in my body, what they were feeling. And I was 23 or something like that. I was young. And it was just too much. You know, knowing their trauma and knowing their circumstances and knowing that they've been abused in all different types of ways and then feeling what they feel and feeling their response to their parents
感受到了孩子们正在感受的东西，我对他们有真正的同理心，但程度似乎超过了我的同事。我要么对他们的感受有很好的了解，要么我实际上在身体上感受到了他们正在感受的东西。我当时23岁左右。我很年轻。这太沉重了。你知道，了解他们的创伤，了解他们的情况，了解他们受到各种各样的虐待，然后感受他们的感受，感受他们对父母的反应，
and their parents' response to them. And it was just too much. And I'd been somebody that had felt other people's emotions all of my life and I was kind of okay with that. But in that intense environment, it was hard. And I didn't have the self-given acknowledgement that I'm a highly sensitive person back then. It was just the way I'd always been and the way I always was. And I wouldn't change that.
以及他们父母对他们的反应。这实在太沉重了。我一生中一直是一个能感受到他人情绪的人，我对此还算适应。但在那种紧张的环境中，这很难。当时我并没有给自己贴上“高敏感人群”的标签。这只是我一直以来的样子。我不会改变这一点。
But what I have done, what I have learned is that I'm not always picking up on energy. I'm not always picking up on the way somebody feels and what's going on for them internally, you know, and externally. And that has made a huge difference to my life. And that's what I bring to a lot of my clients because I work with a lot of sensitive people and empaths. Yeah, it's a big job we do, isn't it? And I think we're more likely to be able to hopefully tune in to others' resonance and their frequency and their emotions and more likely to get it and get why it matters and to be able to kind of piece together some of their story and almost go with it.
但我所做的是，我所学到的是，我并不总是需要去捕捉能量。我并不总是需要去捕捉某人的感受以及他们内在和外在正在发生的事情。这给我的生活带来了巨大的改变。这就是我带给许多客户的东西，因为我与许多敏感的人和共情者一起工作。是的，我们做的工作很重要，不是吗？我认为我们更有可能希望能够调频到他人的共鸣、频率和情绪上，更有可能理解并明白为什么这很重要，并能够拼凑出他们故事的一部分，几乎与他们同行。
But that's not without its negatives as well if you're doing that with all of the people that you're working with because you know it's knowing how and when to to disconnect from that that it's not your stuff that it's that it's someone else's and the way I do it I guess is to think about doing the best possible job I can do at that moment. And the bits I've struggled with is when systems or finances mean that I can't do what I deem to be the best for that person. So it might be that there's a really long waiting list. And I found that personally really, really difficult. So actually, I thought that, yeah, this would be the ideal pathway, you know, gold standard in terms of waiting and in terms of what that person needs and what is going to work for
但如果你与所有你共事的人都这样做，那也不是没有负面影响的。因为你知道，知道如何以及何时从中抽离，知道那不是你的东西，而是别人的东西，这很重要。我想我做的方式是考虑在那个时刻尽我所能做到最好。我挣扎的地方是当系统或财务意味着我无法做到我认为对那个人最好的事情时。所以可能是因为等待名单非常长。我个人觉得这非常非常困难。所以实际上，我认为，是的，这将是理想的途径，你知道，在等待时间和那个人需要什么以及什么最有可能对他们有效方面达到黄金标准。
them or have a best chance of working for them. But when I can't do that because of my hands being tied that's when I find that it leads me further to disillusionment and burnout. Yeah I agree with you there about the system I'd like to to pick up on it it's not that I was overthinking it or it's not that I was you know taking it home in the way way that other people take their work home. You know, I'm not saying I didn't do that. There was one occasion where I did. This child is in such a ridiculous situation, in my opinion,
但当我因为束手束脚而无法做到这一点时，我发现这会导致我进一步陷入幻灭和精疲力竭。是的，我同意你关于系统的看法。我想指出的是，并不是我过度思考了，也不是我像其他人把工作带回家那样把工作带回家。你知道，我不是说我没这样做过。有一次我确实这样做了。在我看来，这个孩子处于一种荒谬的境地，
and the way that he was being treated and, you know, and the way the system was built up up and that's the morning i crashed my car they they decided that they couldn't help this child he was going to be put in um a locked psychiatric unit that's what happened back then and i was honestly i was just fumingly angry i was just i was like you cannot do this. I'm his key worker. I know more about this child than anyone else. And for you to go behind my back and do this is like, and they were like, but we're not going behind your back.
他被对待的方式，以及系统建立的方式……就在我撞车的那天早上，他们决定他们无法帮助这个孩子，他将被送进一个封闭的精神病房。当时就是这样发生的。我真的非常愤怒，我当时想：“你们不能这样做。我是他的关键工作者。我比任何人都了解这个孩子。你们背着我做这种事，就像……”他们说：“但我们没有背着你。”
This is, this has been scheduled and it's not personal. And I get that it wasn't personal, but I had such a relationship with his child and I believe that we could really change him. But they had decided amongst the doctors that they were going to go down a different route. But being a highly sensitive person, the emotions and the empathy are much stronger you feel things much deeper so and the difference a highly sensitive person doesn't feel it in their body they they just know what that person's feeling and then they they may then feel what they feel about that in their they will definitely feel what they feel about that in their body. And it's just a level of sensitivity that works beautifully in these environments. But it also makes it really difficult unless you can turn it off. And as also as an
“这是预先安排好的，不是针对个人的。”我明白这不是针对个人的，但我与这个孩子有这样的关系，我相信我们真的可以改变他。但医生们已经决定走另一条路。但作为一个高敏感的人，情绪和同理心要强烈得多，你感受事物要深刻得多。所以，高敏感的人不会在身体上感受到它，他们只是知道那个人在感受什么，然后他们可能会在身体上感受到他们对这件事的感受。这是一种在这些环境中运作得非常好的敏感度。但除非你能关掉它，否则这也会让事情变得非常困难。而且作为一个
empath, you know, someone would, one of the kids would come in and kick off and and I would feel what they was feeling I'd feel the rage or the upset or whatever it was and they'd also be part of me and and this was I'd be like I get that I get that you're doing that right now and in fact I think that's good for you just just let him carry on. Let him do it. There's nothing here that he can harm himself with. Just let him blow it out. And they'll be like, no, no, no, no, let's sedate him. And I'll be like, well, no, you know. And when I had the authority and I could stop that sedation, I did.
共情者，你知道，其中一个孩子会进来发脾气，我会感受到他们正在感受的东西，我会感受到愤怒或不安或任何东西。他们也会成为我的一部分，我会想：“我明白，我明白你现在正在这样做。”事实上，我认为这对你有好处，就让他继续吧。让他做吧。这里没有什么东西可以伤害到他。让他发泄出来。他们会说：“不，不，不，让我们给他镇静剂。”我会说：“嗯，不。”当我有权阻止那种镇静时，我就阻止了。
And, you know, and most of the time it worked really beautifully the kid blew off steam did what they did you know of course if they was going to hurt themselves or hurt someone else I would step in I'd literally physically step in and I'm quite a small person and most of the adolescents are much bigger than me but they they trusted me and I had a rapport with them that I would get them to look in my eyes and they would just instantly calm down. So that was all beautiful, but I wasn't allowed to work the way that I saw and I wanted. So like you, I agree with you. And that was difficult.
而且，你知道，大多数时候它运作得非常漂亮，孩子发泄了情绪，做了他们做的事。当然，如果他们要伤害自己或伤害别人，我会介入，我会从字面上身体介入。我是一个很小的人，大多数青少年都比我大得多，但他们信任我，我和他们建立了融洽的关系，我会让他们看着我的眼睛，他们就会立刻平静下来。所以这一切都很美好，但我被不允许以我所看到和想要的方式工作。所以像你一样，我同意你的观点。那很困难。
And, yeah, I was a little arrogant. I had all these ideas. I just finished uni and and everything else but I was very passionate and caring about the kids and and that's what made me burn out yeah I think you know absolutely if we're not helping people to experience their full range of emotions which includes the hypo aroused bits as well as the hypo aroused bits. We're not necessarily equipping people with the skills to be able to handle it next time. If you, you know, if you're being sedated, then you go from hyper aroused to then,
而且，是的，我当时有点傲慢。我有很多想法。我刚从大学毕业，还有其他一切，但我对孩子们非常热情和关心，这就是让我精疲力竭的原因。是的，我认为，你知道，绝对地，如果我们不帮助人们体验他们全部的情绪范围，包括高唤醒状态和低唤醒状态，我们就不一定能让人们具备下次处理它的技能。如果你，你知道，如果你被镇静了，那么你就从高唤醒状态变成了，
you know, waking up and wondering what's going on, but you've missed that middle bit of, of where you calm down um and that I think that is potentially difficult and I think there's an interesting you know interesting food for thought there in letting people safely you know process and manage their thoughts feelings and emotions could you tell us a little bit about how you stepped away from your psychology career? Yeah, hitting the tree was really a wake-up call. So ironically, I had, you know, six weeks ago, because of the high emotion and high energy of the job, you know, it was a brilliant hospital that I worked in and they were running a new system.
你知道，醒来后想知道发生了什么，但你错过了中间平静下来的那部分。我认为这可能很困难，我认为这里有一个有趣的……你知道，有趣的思考点，即让人们安全地处理和管理他们的思想、感受和情绪。你能告诉我们一点你是如何离开心理学职业生涯的吗？是的，撞到树是一个真正的警钟。所以讽刺的是，因为工作的强烈情绪和高能量，你知道，我工作的医院很棒，他们正在运行一个新系统。
That's why I chose this hospital to work in. And there was a lot of things that worked really well in it, I'd like to say that, and it was a massive education for me, being there, working there. But just before I hit the tree six weeks ago, I had taken an active holiday because I knew that I needed to do something. I needed time out of work. I needed to do something.
这就是我选择这家医院工作的原因。我想说，其中有很多事情运作得非常好，在那里工作对我来说是一次巨大的教育。但在我撞到树的前六周，我休了一个积极的假期，因为我知道我需要做点什么。我需要从工作中抽身。我需要做点什么。
So I went on what I thought was a beginner's course in sports massage. But the lady had put me on an intermediate course because of my qualifications, anatomy and physiology. And she just said, look, if you don't like it, you can go home and you can do the other course because it was a residential course. I said, okay. So there I was, 10 days. And I was a natural and I passed with flying colours.
所以我参加了我认为是运动按摩的初级课程。但那位女士因为我的解剖学和生理学资格，把我安排到了中级课程。她只是说：“看，如果你不喜欢，你可以回家，你可以参加另一个课程。”因为这是一个住宿课程。我说：“好吧。”所以我就在那里待了10天。我很有天赋，我以优异的成绩通过了。
So I was now an unexpectedly qualified sports massage therapist. And when I hit the tree and I had various injuries um my I used my own knowledge and got got most of me better you know I had whiplash um so that's what I treated what I didn't know is it also um really really hurt my left hip but that didn't that didn't show up physically until a month later um and so you know I started getting treatment for for my hip a month later and the guy was technically excellent but his best high manner was dreadful and that was private it wasn't through the NHS and I just thought I could do this. So I started doing it part-time with just people around me. And within a year, I had enough client base to stop my job
所以我现在成了一名意想不到的合格运动按摩治疗师。当我撞到树并受了各种伤时，我运用我自己的知识，让我大部分身体好转了。你知道，我有挥鞭伤，所以我治疗了那个。我不知道的是，它也真的真的伤到了我的左髋，但这直到一个月后才在身体上表现出来。所以，你知道，一个月后我开始接受髋部治疗，那个人技术上很出色，但他的床边态度很糟糕。那是私人的，不是通过NHS的。我只是想我可以做到这一点。所以我开始兼职做这件事，只为周围的人服务。一年之内，我就有了足够的客户群来停止我的工作，
and to do that full-time. And that's what I did. So I just dropped being a psychologist. But ironically, at least 50% of the people that came to me wanted to come to me for mental problems and I had to keep saying but I'm no longer a psychologist you know let's you know is there anything school you want and so eventually I just gave in and I started treating both and that's how I created my own therapy. Lovely thank you for sharing that with us.
并全职做这件事。这就是我所做的。所以我放弃了做心理学家。但讽刺的是，来找我的至少50%的人想因为心理问题来找我，我不得不一直说：“但我不再是心理学家了，你知道，让我们看看有什么学校你想要的。”所以最终我屈服了，我开始两者都治疗，这就是我创造自己疗法的方式。太可爱了，谢谢你与我们分享这些。
Have you got any tips or advice for if people are listening to this and they're starting to notice that itch that might need scratching, that a mental health career in professional psychology might not be for them anymore? Yeah, I think for me what I needed to do was just look at well what what do I love what do I spend my time thinking about you know when I'm not at work what what thoughts go through my head what is it that I really love about my work what is it I love about the studies that I've done what books am I reading what films am I watching? What conversations am I having? And out of all of that, I was like, yeah, I really like sports.
如果人们正在听这个节目，并且他们开始注意到那个可能需要抓挠的痒处，即心理健康职业中的专业心理学可能不再适合他们了，你有什么建议或忠告吗？是的，我认为对我来说，我需要做的是看看我喜欢什么，我花时间思考什么。你知道，当我不在工作时，什么想法会出现在我的脑海里？我真正喜欢工作的什么？我喜欢我所做的研究的什么？我在读什么书？我在看什么电影？我在进行什么对话？在所有这些之中，我想：“是的，我真的很喜欢运动。”
I really thought I'd always done sport. And I thought, you know, I really like sports. So, yeah, I would be interested in doing that. And I'm still really helping the person. Because what I noticed in the psychiatric unit was all of the children also had physical problems. All of them had. You know, they might have been small, they might have been bigger. And then, yeah, I pretty quickly realised
我一直认为我一直做运动。我想：“你知道，我真的很喜欢运动。”所以，是的，我有兴趣做那个。而且我仍然在真正地帮助那个人。因为我在精神病房注意到的是，所有的孩子也有身体问题。他们都有。你知道，他们可能很小，他们可能更大。然后，是的，我很快意识到
that the majority of people that came to see me for massage, they also had, like, maybe it was stress, maybe it was depression, or maybe it was something much bigger like trauma and things like that um so i became more and more interested in the link between the physical body and the physical problems and the mental problems and psychological problems and that led me to studying craniosacral therapy because that brings the two of them together so yeah so to answer your question in case it's been lost is to really look at what it is you love and what excites and interests you and in where does that lead you to great and would you say that you are fulfilled and happy and pleased in your in your sphere of work currently oh absolutely um you know when I start every session with a name and at the end of the session you know I I ask them about that
大多数来找我做按摩的人，他们也有，比如，可能是压力，可能是抑郁，或者可能是像创伤之类更大的事情。所以我对身体与身体问题、心理问题和心理学问题之间的联系越来越感兴趣，这引导我学习颅骶疗法，因为它将两者结合在一起。所以，是的，回答你的问题，以防它被遗忘了，就是真正看看你喜欢什么，什么让你兴奋和感兴趣，以及这把你引向哪里。太棒了。你会说你目前在你的工作领域感到满足、快乐和高兴吗？哦，绝对。你知道，我以一个名字开始每一次会话，在会话结束时，你知道，我问他们关于那个，
and I might even poke it a little bit to make sure that it's cleared and it just amazes me the journey the session goes on and then to to see the person's face when they realize something and particularly when they let go of it and I help them let go of even more of it it's just wonderful I just I just love it so professional psychology is not the only way to make you happy. And that might be a really interesting and useful point for people if they are starting to feel that this is not for me. It's not making me happy. I feel like I'm burning out. There must be another way.
我甚至可能会稍微戳一下它以确保它已经清除了，这让我感到惊讶，会话经历的旅程，然后看到当他们意识到某事时那个人的脸，特别是当他们放手时，我帮助他们放手更多，这真是太美妙了。我只是，我只是喜欢它。所以专业心理学不是让你快乐的唯一途径。如果人们开始觉得这不适合我，这让我不快乐，我觉得我快要精疲力竭了，这可能是一个非常有趣和有用的观点。一定有另一种方式。
There might well be. This isn't for everybody. Have you got a take-home message for people who might be listening today Fiona? To be who they really are to ground inside of themselves to connect to who who they really are and to explore that and dare to lift that dare to be who they really are and show that and be inspired by or they're inspired by to go with their intuition because I don't believe that anybody can work as a psychologist and not intuitively feel something about their clients, their patients, whatever they call them and that might not add up when they think about the theory or might not add up to what they are expected to
可能确实有。这并不适合每个人。Fiona，你对今天可能正在收听的人有什么带回家的信息吗？成为他们真正的人，扎根于他们自己，连接到他们真正的人，探索这一点，敢于提升这一点，敢于成为他们真正的人，展示这一点，并受到启发，或者他们受到启发，跟随他们的直觉。因为我不相信任何人可以作为心理学家工作而不直觉地感受到关于他们的客户、他们的病人，无论他们称呼他们为什么，而这在他们思考理论时可能加起来不成立，或者可能加起来不符合他们被期望
do but if they feel it inside of themselves and they know it dare to go with that dare to go their own insights and see where that gets their time yeah i absolutely agree you know you should feel like you're being yourself like you're being authentic and that you're vibrant in your work you know i think absolutely that's the case and and I believe that about myself and my work currently for sure where's the best place for people to connect with you or learn more about you if they want to Fiona on LinkedIn and my name's Fiona McGuire Fiona is f-i-o-n-a and McGuire's m-a-g-u-i-r-e and also my website is the same www.fionamcguire.com without any spaces and i i give away there's free resources the grounding that I've mentioned how to work with your energy which is a book and yeah people get a lot of benefit out of them and I'm always happy to chat with somebody on LinkedIn
做的事情。但如果他们在内心深处感受到了，并且他们知道它，敢于去那样做。敢于去他们自己的洞察力，看看那把他们带到哪里。是的，我绝对同意。你知道，你应该感觉你正在做你自己，就像你正在变得真实，并且你在你的工作中充满活力。你知道，我认为绝对是这样。而且我肯定相信关于我自己和我的工作。如果人们想与你联系或了解更多关于你的信息，Fiona，最好的地方在哪里？在LinkedIn上，我的名字是Fiona Maguire，Fiona是F-I-O-N-A，Maguire是M-A-G-U-I-R-E。而且我的网站也是一样的，www.fionamcguire.com，没有任何空格。而且我提供免费资源，我提到的扎根，如何与你的能量一起工作，这是一本书。是的，人们从中得到了很多好处。我总是很高兴在LinkedIn上与某人聊天。
brilliant thank you so much I'll pop all your details in the show notes as well but not everyone accesses the show notes so it's always useful to have said that out loud as well thank you so much for your time today, Fiona, and for helping us answer the question, what happens if you decide psychology is not for you? I know that you still work in the psychology sphere, but professional psychology, because that's a lot of our audience. So thank you so much for your time and so generously sharing your rich insights with us.
太棒了，非常感谢。我也会把你的所有细节放在节目说明中，但不是每个人都能访问节目说明，所以大声说出来也总是很有用的。非常感谢你今天的时间，Fiona，并帮助我们回答了这个问题：如果你决定心理学不适合你，会发生什么？我知道你仍然在心理学领域工作，但专业心理学，因为那是我们许多听众的领域。所以非常感谢你的时间，并如此慷慨地与我们分享你丰富的见解。
Thank you very much. Really good to speak with you. Thank you so much for my guest, Fiona Maguire, for coming along and talking with us. I hope you found that to be a useful listen. Like I said, if you want to connect with Fiona, do check the details in my show notes and that will help put you in touch. If you are still wanting to pursue professional psychology and you're ready for the next step, then do please check out the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book, the Clinical Psychologist Collective book, and do consider joining the Aspiring Psychologist membership. We're a really lovely group that is supportive, that helps you towards your goals. And I help you with anything that you think,
非常感谢。和你交谈真的很好。非常感谢我的嘉宾Fiona Maguire来到这里并与我们交谈。我希望你觉得这是一个有用的聆听。就像我说的，如果你想与Fiona联系，请查看我节目说明中的细节，这将有助于让你与她取得联系。如果你仍然想追求专业心理学，并且你准备好迈出下一步，那么请查看《有抱负的心理学家集体》书，《临床心理学家集体》书，并考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员”。我们是一个非常可爱的群体，是支持性的，帮助你实现你的目标。我帮助你解决任何你认为，
oh, I'm a bit worried about that. Then I will find an expert to talk to us about it, to help you, guide you through that process. And that's certainly the case with something we've got happening in the membership. Today, as I record this, we are covering selection tests, logical and deductive reasoning tests. So if on replay you're listening to this, you're thinking, oh, I'd like to learn more about that, then you might well find the membership useful for that too. I would love your reviews, your audio testimonials of the podcast and of the books too. It's really simple to do that. If you head to my website www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast, then just click on the audio testimonial option. And with a few clicks and a couple of minutes, you will have done that. Thank you so much for your time. Do come and
“哦，我对此有点担心。”那么我会找一位专家来和我们谈谈，来帮助你，引导你完成那个过程。这当然是我们会员中正在发生的事情的情况。今天，当我录制这个时，我们正在涵盖选择测试、逻辑和演绎推理测试。所以如果你在重播时正在听这个，你正在想，“哦，我想学习更多关于那个的信息，”那么你很可能会发现会员对那个也很有用。我想要你的评论，你的播客和书的音频推荐。这样做真的很简单。如果你前往我的网站www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast，然后只需点击音频推荐选项。只需点击几下和几分钟，你就会完成那个。非常感谢你的时间。来吧，
connect with me on socials. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent in all places that you might hope to find me. And yeah, I'm really looking forward to connecting with you and helping you in your journey as an aspiring psychologist. Thank you so much for being part of my world. Take care. Reflective accounts of mental health professionals on their way to getting qualified. So many tips and lessons to learn from. So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective With this podcast that you'll see, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast.
在社交媒体上与我联系。我是Dr. Marianne Trent，在所有你可能希望找到我的地方。是的，我真的很期待与你联系，并在你作为有抱负的心理学家的旅程中帮助你。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。保重。心理健康专业人士在获得资格道路上的反思性叙述。有这么多提示和课程可以学习。有这么多你可以尝试的事情。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。有了这个你将看到的播客，你将在获得资格的道路上。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》。
With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是Dr. Marianne Trent。我的名字是Jana，我是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容真的很有趣。这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，没有完美的途径可以成为一个，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，并减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这个，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的，但相信我，一旦你开始，你就不会放下这本书。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。